the waiting it is finally over on this
election day can you believe it it's
here
now it's up to you you the people to
make your voices heard
joe biden and president trump have both
made their closing arguments
biden was in his home state of
pennsylvania where he will return today
the president was in grand rapids
michigan in the same place he closed out
his 2016 campaign
he'll be watching the returns that the
white house 400 people have been invited
to that viewing party
we've already seen unprecedented early
turnout for this election it's estimated
nearly 100 million americans have
already voted
this morning many are already lined up
for what could be
the highest election turnout in u.s
history
we've got correspondents throughout the
country following every aspect of this
momentous day
we'll start with ben tracy at the white
house ben good morning
good morning so there is now
non-scalable fencing surrounding the
entire white house complex and they
expect that to stay up through the rest
of the week obviously what happens today
will determine who lives in this house
for the next four years
and the two candidates battled it out in
the battlegrounds until the final
moments
of the campaign we want to do it just
like last time but let's give me a
little bit more margin than that if you
don't mind
[Applause]
joined by his running mate and his
family president trump held his last
rally of the campaign
in the same place he ended his run for
the white house back in 2016.
grand rapids michigan i kept saying we
have to finish off here
we have to do it it's just that we can
be a little bit superstitious right
on monday the president made five stops
in four different
and important swing states i am asking
you tomorrow to go out
and vote for your all-time favorite
president
mr trump claims he's confident but he's
also threatening legal action before
any election results have even been
announced could he really win
are we serious about this
[Applause]
in pennsylvania he railed against the
supreme court's decision allowing
pennsylvania's law on mail-in ballots to
stand
the law allows ballots to be counted
that arrive up to three days after the
election
as long as they're postmarked by
election day they made a very dangerous
situation
and i mean danger is physically
dangerous and they made it a very very
bad they did a very bad thing for the
state
they did a very bad thing for this
nation a tweet later released by the
president with a similar message
was quickly flagged for misleading
information about the election
and there's a battle over the votes
already cast in texas a federal court of
appeals blocked a republican-led effort
to invalidate nearly 127 thousand drive
through ballots
in heavily democratic harris county the
county clerk decided to close nine of
ten drive-through voting sites
to avoid further risk the president
seems to be trying to link any delay in
the results to fraud which could then
result in violence but it is important
to note that it is not unusual not to
have an official winner on election
night in fact it never happens while
news organizations may project a winner
it's up to states to keep counting their
ballots and then officially certify
a winner in every state tony very
important reminder there ben thank you
very much